homeland security secretary Kirsten
Nelson says the government will meet
today's deadline to reunite all eligible
children and parents who were separated
at the border at this moment more than
500 families are still waiting to be
reunited that's a good news but the very
bad news is another 463 parents have
been deported without their children and
word is they may never be reunited
initially more than 2,500 children
between the ages of 5 and 17 were
separated from their families but a avea
rial is in Albuquerque New Mexico where
many eligible families are being sent
for reunification today a good morning
well good morning Albuquerque has become
one of the hubs for these reunifications
happening at shelters like the family
lutheran center right behind me but
there are still over 900 children
between the ages of 5 and 18 that are
considered ineligible so they will stay
in the government's custody past today's
deadline now ineligible means that the
person they came with when they crossed
over is not their parent or they might
have a criminal history
Albuquerque's departure terminal is
where once separated families are
finding a fresh start
Rome Ella Victoria assala and her son
Geronimo are heading to their new home
in Massachusetts after being separated
for two months he sala recalls the
moment she says her son was torn from
her we arrived at immigration and they
screamed at me because I was crying over
my son she says I didn't know where they
would take him I didn't know if they
were going to treat him well Rome Ella
and Geronimo are just two of almost 1200
immigrant families who have been brought
back together under a federal court
order
in Baltimore seven-year-old Andy
couldn't hold back his tears after
seeing his mother out alley for the
first time in nearly a month the
government hasn't taken the proper steps
to effectively deny these parents the
right to their children Virginia based
attorney Sophia Gregg represents out
Ellie and Andy like most families who've
been reunited the two will have to wait
for their Asylum case to be heard by a
judge and they still face the risk of
deportation there's also a large number
of families or parents that the
government has determined are ineligible
to be reunited the city is expecting to
receive about 300 families these
separated families are coming through
here but they will not stay for very
long the goal of these organizations is
to get them out on a plane and to their
final destination in less than 24 hours
Nora all right Maria thank you